pienso que será bueno que veamos un
problema en donde se aplique la doble
ranura de jong tenemos una luz con
longitud de onda de 700 nanómetros que
significa la distancia de aquí acá la
longitud de onda brilla a través de una
doble ranura cuyos agujeros son de 200
nanómetros de ancho significa que de
aquí acá hay 200 nanómetros y tienen un
espacio entre ellos de 1300 nanómetros
quiere decir que del centro de este
punto al centro de este otro punto hay
1300 nanómetros si una pantalla se
coloca a tres metros de distancia de la
doble ranura es decir de aquí a acá son
tres metros cuál será la distancia del
punto central brillante de la pantalla
al siguiente punto brillante bueno el
punto central es esta línea que se ve un
poco sombreada justo aquí este es el
punto de interferencia constructiva cuál
será la distancia del punto central
brillante de este de la pantalla al
siguiente punto brillante estas líneas
como sombreadas nos indican dónde están
los puntos de interferencia constructiva
y queremos saber la distancia del
central a este de aquí entonces la
pregunta es cuál es la distancia de aquí
acá esto es lo que me preguntan pues
vamos a usar la ecuación que encontramos
nuestra fórmula es de por el seno de
theta esta es nuestra fórmula y
recordamos que esta fórmula es nuestra
diferencia en la longitud de la ruta y
encontramos que esto es igual a m por
lambda a veces se van a encontrar en
lugar de esta m una n n por lambda pero
a mí no me gusta usar la n porque me
confunde con el índice de refracción que
es d
es la distancia entre las ranuras por lo
tanto esta es mi de que mide estos 1.300
nanómetros así que tengo 1300 nanómetros
por el seno del ángulo y este ángulo
cual es bueno yo quiero conocer la
distancia de aquí entonces el ángulo que
me interesa va a ser el que se forma
entre la línea central y este punto de
aquí arriba en la pantalla este ángulo
de acá esto va a ser igual a que valor
de m bueno m no va a ser cero porque no
me interesa esta línea central me
interesa este punto de acá por lo que me
va a ser igual a uno el primer punto en
donde tengo una interferencia
constructiva después el punto central y
esto va a estar x 701 metros y ustedes
me pueden decir a ver un momento y qué
pasa con estos 200 nanómetros esto
solamente se refiere al ancho de la
abertura de la ranura y este dato no lo
vamos a usar no lo vamos a usar en
nuestros cálculos simplemente nos indica
que el ancho de este agujero es muy muy
pequeño lo suficientemente pequeño como
para tener difracción un ángulo de
difracción lo suficientemente ancho como
para que se pueda dar este
diferencia y así se forme el patrón de
interferencia que veremos aquí pero
bueno en este caso no vamos a usar este
dato para nuestros cálculos vamos a
encontrar este ángulo entonces tenemos
que 1 x 700 nanómetros es igual a 700
nanómetros dividido a ambos lados entre
1300 nanómetros y me queda que el seno
del ángulo theta es igual a 700
entre 1300 los nano metros se cancelan
con los nanómetros aquí como estoy
teniendo las mismas unidades pues se van
a cancelar y aquí quiero encontrar theta
como encuentro theta pues tengo que usar
el seno inverso en ambos lados de la
igualdad
cuál es el seno inverso de seno pues va
a ser el ángulo esto es igual al seno
inverso de estos 700 entre 1300
700 entre 1300 y esto nos va a dar 32
puntos 6 grados
este es el ángulo de aquí pero no me
están pidiendo el ángulo me están
pidiendo esta distancia bueno a este
lado le voy a llamar detalle porque luce
como una distancia vertical este es el
lado opuesto a mi ángulo este es el lado
opuesto y conocemos el lado adyacente
nos han indicado que esto mide 3 metros
esto está alejado tres metros nuestra
pantalla está alejada 3 metros y como
relacionamos el lado opuesto con el lado
adyacente caray pues vamos a usar la
tangente de teta
y la tangente de teta es el lado opuesto
que es este entre el lado adyacente esto
es igual a del talle entre
nuestros tres metros y si despejó del
taller de esto qué es lo que me interesa
nos va a quedar que el taller es igual
multiplicamos ambos lados por tres
metros y va a ser igual a tres metros
multiplicado por la tangente detecta y
ya encontramos cual éste está entonces
es la tangente de 32 puntos 6 grados y
esto nos va a dar todo esto nos va a dar
1.92 metros
esta es la distancia desde aquí
hasta acá 1.92 metros y es así como
resolvemos este problema usamos un poco
de trigonometría una vez que encontramos
nuestro ángulo lo relacionamos con la
distancia vertical de la pantalla y este
es un problema bastante típico de la
doble ranura de jong y algo que voy a
agregar es otra pregunta bastante común
nos dicen qué sucede si reducimos esta
distancia entre las ranuras si reducimos
esta distancia y juntamos más estas
ranuras este ángulo se hará más pequeño
o más grande matemáticamente si vemos
nuestra fórmula y está de disminuye
noten que no puedo cambiar la longitud
de onda esto está determinado por el
láser que estoy proyectando aquí así que
la longitud de onda permanece igual por
lo que esto permanece constante y todo
este lado no cambia m sigue siendo 1 ya
que me estoy refiriendo al primer punto
que está después del punto central
qué pasa con el ángulo si disminuyó mi
distancia y eso permanece constante pues
esto también tiene que permanecer igual
por lo tanto mi ángulo theta tiene que
aumentar ya que el seno de un ángulo más
grande me va a dar un número más grande
el seno de cero es cero y el seno de
algo más grande va a ser un número más
grande así que mientras más grande sea
mi theta mayor será mi ángulo mayor será
el número de aquí así que si esto tiene
que permanecer igual y disminuye mi
distancia esto tiene que aumentar y esa
es la forma matemática de responderlo
pero también se los puedo mostrar
visualmente miren esto tomo todo esto y
lo voy a mover hacia abajo vean qué es
lo que sucede noten cómo estas líneas
oscuras se van esparciendo y conforme
más las acerco más se van esparciendo
notan como estas líneas oscuras se van
esparciendo y es curioso cómo estas
líneas constructivas en esta imagen se
ven oscuras pero es así como se
visualiza
y si voy alejando las ranuras voy a
tener más de estas líneas oscuras que me
indican la interferencia constructiva y
conforme junto a las ranuras éstas se
van a separar
así que si yo juntará estas ranuras
ustedes lo que verían es estos puntos
constructivos alejarse más entre sí esto
es lo que veríamos en la pantalla y esta
es una aplicación de la doble ranura de
jong